- I look at it as phenomenal,
because AI's gonna do shit
that below average humans do poorly.
(crowd laughs)
Yeah!
- Yeah!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
- [Gary] I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(jazzy midtempo music)
(hip hop influenced pop rock music)
♪ Got so much weight on ♪
- By being patient.
I mean, as long as you
live under their roof,
you're playing by their rules, so
either stop taking their money
and move out and then
you live on your own,
whether you're 17 or 23.
Or just be patient and
appreciate their opinions,
but live your own life.
And don't require them to do anything.
Your parents and many
people's parents here
bring a ton of value,
and I feel like a lot of people
continue to ask them to do more.
Just don't ask.
Live your life.
(reflective piano music)
- [Man] You inspire
people all over the world,
every day, across
multiple channels online.
I've got to ask, what inspires you?
Both here and in the past?
- Optimism.
Optimism inspires me.
People who have very little,
who have severe challenges
and persevere.
Maybe this is where I'm
so affected by my mother.
My mother lost her
mother when she was five.
She grew up in the depths
of Soviet Communist Russia.
Her father went to jail for a decade.
She's the most optimistic person I know.
When people come up to
me and they're like,
oh I have it so,
I'm like, I always just
think about my mom.
You know, she's so positive.
So optimistic.
And she had such shit as a child.
You know?
- [Man] Gary, I don't
want to end on a downer
but you often talk about how people should
- [Gary] Real quick,
I don't think what I just
said about my mom's a downer,
I think it's an interesting insight.
I actually think adversity
is the great gift
in our society.
And I think if you really look at
who's upset for real,
it's the people that grew up entitled
and are then zoo animals
when they go into society,
'cause they were so over-coddled.
Not the ones who have
chips on their shoulders
and had a lot of negativity.
Oh man, it's in five minutes.
God, I'm so nervous.
Pbbbbt.
Today's the NBA Lottery
and there's an incredible
basketball player in college, Zion.
- [Sportscaster] That's Zion, baby!
That's Zion!
- Who everybody wants and
the Knicks are one of
the teams in the running
to get the ping pong ball.
It's a big day. (whispering)
- Gary V was telling me
about The Bachelorette, which also is just
(laughs)
just debuting this week.
- We're in top four?
- [Man On Phone] Yes.
- And we have the best chance.
We made it to the commercial!
Let's go!
- Any balls yet?
- Yeah, they're done!
Everybody's, it's the
Pelicans, the Grizzlies,
the Lakers and the Knicks.
- Who has the those are all the top five.
- That's the top four.
They're coming back on commercial.
Lakers got it?
What's that?
I know we do.
Let's go.
- Thanks a lot.
- Cheers.
- [Camerawoman] 'kay, I tried.
- All right, I'll be right back.
- The third pick goes to
(envelope opens)
the New York Knicks.
- No!
Third.
- [Man] Knicks?
- God damn it!
God damn it!
(crowd talking)
The Pelicans got it?
- [Man] Number one pick?
- Pelicans.
(inaudible)
- This was 1985, there'd
be a zero percent chance
of one of those teams
getting the first pick.
- [Gary] This the best part.
(laughs)
(video)
Gary Vee is very upset
that Zion's not coming to New York.
(laughs)
That's my favorite part.
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuck!
Woo!
(applauding)
- Ready?
- Yep!
Bye guys.
- Here he comes.
- Thank you, man.
(dance music)
(applauding, cheers)
What up?!
Thank you.
(applauding)
- [Audience Member] Gary!
- The Knicks didn't get Zion, so I'm dead.
So, energy's going to be down
at least one solid notch.
- You think we're in an AI arms race?
And where do you think that ends?
- You know, one thing I
really am passionate about
that's evolved for me and
I'm thankful for it is,
I try not to talk about
shit that I don't know.
So, the answer is I'm not sure.
I haven't done enough homework on AI
to answer that thoughtfully
like the other questions.
I think it's inevitable.
The technology's inevitable,
but I think people grossly
underestimate human beings.
We evolved into other shit.
I think AI is gonna do a lot of dumb shit
that we shouldn't be doing anyway.
And it's going to be impactful,
but not the way,
I don't think this, I think
this could be a precursor
to the robots killing us.
(audience laughs)
Which I do think is inevitable.
I think we'll miss it,
thank God.
But I think our grandkids might be fucked,
you know?
(audience laughs)
But I think what AI's gonna do is,
and if you're talking about an arm's race
between China and the U.S.,
if you're talking about
humans verus robots,
technology eliminates commodity.
And I think AI is going to
eliminate a lot of things
that don't bring value in 2026,
and I think those humans
will find other things to do.
Listen.
I got, first of all, thank you so much.
A lot of you do follow me.
A lot of you know I was
a really bad student,
and I love always posting my
ridiculously bad report card.
But there's one really interesting insight
that I hope helps everybody here.
Besides Gym,
the one class that I
did well in was History.
And I've only now started
to understand why.
I basically use history very heavily
to decide what's gonna happen next.
Everybody who's talking about AI is so bad
all this, these articles
were written about
machinery around farming.
We just knew that we were all farming!
We went on to do other shit.
We're gonna do other shit.
And by the way, I don't
feel bad for a truck driver
who isn't reading headlines for 20 years
that autonomous trucks are coming.
We gave him 20 fuckin' years!
(audience laughs)
When they cry, in 2039,
like, ah the fuckin'
autonomous trucks took me out,
I'm like, dick, you had 20 years!
(audience laughs)
You couldn't have learned another skill
along the way, asshole?
(audience applauds)
I mean this, and I see
so many clapping, listen.
Listen, I'm unbelievably
I have a lot of different thoughts,
but I will say this.
We are living in the
golden era of entitlement.
And the quicker you can get entitlement
out of your body, the better.
And so, yeah.
Technology happens.
I'd much rather be dealing with the
pre-dawn days of AI
then dealing with the black plague.
(audience laughs)
That happened!
To humans!
They lived during a time
where everybody almost fuckin' died!
(audience laughs)
So we complain about dumb shit.
You know?
The Holocaust is recent.
Shit happens!
I'm not worried about fuckin' AI.
Meaning, yes a lot of stuff will happen,
but I don't view it as
this negative arms race.
I look at it as phenomenal,
because AI's gonna do shit that
below average humans do poorly.
(audience laughs, applauds)
Which, and
this is where it's really interesting
to hear that sentence carefully.
It makes me then think that that human
could actually then go do something
that they do like and do well.
That's not like, you suck, human,
no, it's not some rogue shit,
it's actually understanding
how humans work,
which is when you find something you like
and you're good at it,
life is a lot better than when you don't,
or when you just chase money,
or when you dwell that
the system's against you.
I like the pressure of technology.
I think it leads to a lot of happiness
for a lot of people
who can just look at the
other side of the coin.
My friends, you find what
you're looking for in life.
You wanna think everything
is negative and fucked?
You can find that all day as you know.
But if you want to think
there's a ton of opportunity,
and this is the greatest era to be alive,
you can find that too,
'cause the math supports it.
Pick.
(audience cheers, applauds)
All right, headed to the airport,
back to LAX, then Singapore.
You're amazing.
- Do you need a quick trip to
the gentlemen's room or anything?
- No, I'm good.
- Okay, I got a Virgil's
for you in your bag.
- Thank you so much.
Root beer, love it.
- There's your Virgil's
- Love Virgil's.
- It's almost as good as
(chuckles)
Almost.
- Almost.
- Sort of an agency, and
I'm just trying to think
of how to actually prioritize
what I'm doing with work.
I just graduated last week.
How to prioritize what
I'm doing with my job
and what I want to do on my own.
- By building a framework of patience.
If you think you need it tomorrow,
- Yeah.
- You're gonna burn out.
And you're gonna put too
much pressure on yourself.
By realizing that I was
working a cash register
when I was 27 years old,
by really understanding that.
- Yeah.
- You can easily do it,
if you cut out leisure,
if you want it so bad, you can do it.
But, it's gonna take you 26 months
to make that jump, not next week.
- Yeah.
- And I think once you have
a framework of patience,
then you can pull it off.
And I think where everybody gets caught is
everybody wants it so fast
that it fucks them up!
- I feel that.
- Does that makes sense?
- Yeah.
- If you literally said,
okay, if at 26, which
would be young as fuck,
I'm gonna have
- I'm 22
- Right, exactly, I did the math.
(laughs)
Just graduated.
If you said to yourself, at 26
I'm gonna have my own agency,
now all of a sudden,
if you're tired one night
because the job
or if your buddies want to go
and watch the game
seven of the NBA Finals,
now you're not so frantic
that you have to have your fuckin' agency
in six months.
Dude, I've been telling people
I'm gonna buy the Jets when I'm 70,
since I was 15!
You can imagine why that's made it easy.
People are like, you're
gonna own the Jets,
somebody said today,
in six months, Gary Vee,
I'm like, no I'm not!
I don't do that.
Take some of the pressure away,
that will really help you, Ryan.
It really will.
Do you know what I mean?
- Definitely. I do, I
really appreciate it.
- Because then it's not
about being frantic and manic
every night.
All of a sudden, you're
not beating yourself up
one night where you're
just gonna play Fortnite
and drink a beer.
Because you're thinking in 50 year terms
not in 50 day terms.
- Yeah.
There's a lot of time, too.
Can I take a pic with you real quick?
- You can.
Take care, bro.
- All right, thanks again.
- Stay well.
- Safe flight.
♪ You want an honest livin' ♪
♪ But you don't understand ♪
♪ I won't be here waitin' ♪
♪ You wake up again ♪
♪ You want an honest livin' ♪
♪ But you don't understand ♪
♪ I won't be here waitin' ♪
♪ You wake up again ♪